[Musica]
sono sempre stata molto orgogliosa dei
miei quattro nonni
anzi 62 vicini di casa assunti in ruolo
il modello di anziano che ho conosciuto
grazie a loro e di una persona dai modi
semplici ma dalla grande nobiltà d'animo
con mia nonna andavo a messa e una volta
durante la lettura del vangelo sentito
questa frase che mi ha molto colpito
quando eri giovane di change e vi la
veste da solo e andavi dove volevi ma
quando sarai vecchio tenderai le mani un
altro ti cingerà la veste e ti porterà
dove tu non vuoi io dormivo con mia
nonna quell'epoca per me lei era felice
per me tutti gli anziani erano felici ma
quella frase era arrivata e ho iniziato
a pensare non so se anche a voi abbia
fatto questo effetto ma ho pensato
questa possibilità ho realizzato che
essere vecchio può voler dire anche che
qualcun altro decide per te e con questa
considerazione ho vissuto le mie
esperienze lavorative di animatrice in
casa di riposo prima e di coordinatrice
dei volontari oggi con questa attenzione
non pensare di sapere cosa sia meglio
per l'anziano chiedilo a lui
lui lo sa
gli anziani che incontriamo come
volontari dell'associazione un sorriso
in più sono volontari sono soli sono
all'interno di case di riposo in
ospedale e quindi sono persone che sono
dove non vorrebbero essere a volte loro
ci confidano avaria mai pensato
non avrei mai pensato di trovarmi in
questa situazione perché questo
allontanamento lo strappo da casa dal
proprio ambiente
il luogo dove ci sono le nostre
sicurezze i nostri riferimenti per
tendere le braccia a qualcuno che non ti
conosce che non ti riconosce e doloroso
ti rende fragile
per questo con i volontari cerchiamo di
offrire l'opportunità a ogni anziano di
trovare uno spazio al nostro fianco in
cui poter esprimere e sentirsi liberi di
esprimere se stessi la propria unicità
noi siamo volontari di relazione o come
a volte si chiamano i volontari anziani
i volontari delle chiacchiere ed è
corretto noi siamo quelli che si siedono
lì accanto che lasciano parlare che
ascoltano e che non hanno nient'altro da
fare quindi questo sguardo di fronte a
questo sguardo attento curioso
interessato la persona ritrova il
piacere di parlare di sé di svelare chi
è stare di fronte a un anziano che ti
racconta frammenti che ti affido a
momenti della sua storia è davvero
un'esperienza unica
immagino che ognuno di voi abbia provato
l'esperienza di leggere un libro
appassionante stare di fronte a un
anziano è come leggere a farsi
appassionare da un buon libro ti
immedesimi nei personaggi ti lasci
condurre nelle loro vicende attraverso i
loro luoghi per te magari sconosciuti e
partecipi a quel momento ti lasci
coinvolgere sei dentro se poi la
descrizione e ricca di particolari
i tuoi sensi proprio percepiscono i
profumi i sapori di quel momento come
chi legge molto chi ascolta gli anziani
vive più vite e impara qualcosa di sé
nel racconto dell'altro
senti risuonare parti di te i tuoi
sentimenti li riconosci e riesce a
dargli un nome sperimenti anche emozioni
che non avevi mai vissuto
ecco perché per i nostri volontari stare
in compagnia dell'anziano è un
privilegio perché è l'occasione è un
arricchimento e l'occasione per
prendersi cura di sé
ed ecco perché lorella una volontaria
molto cara dice adesso come facciamo
senza i nostri vecchi perché in questo
periodo noi in questo anno così
particolare non possiamo entrare nelle
strutture e vi assicuro che è davvero
difficile farne a meno
e allora cerchiamo dei modi alternativi
per poter stare accanto anche a distanza
in occasione del natale la nostra
associazione realizza un progetto
meraviglioso cioè nel senso che dà vita
a vere e proprie meraviglie e permette a
tanti di scoprire
l'anziano nel 2018 per la prima volta
abbiamo portato in italia un progetto
che invita le persone i nipoti appunto a
realizzare i desideri degli anziani
nelle case di riposo sul sito nipoti di
babbo natale le strutture residenziali
di tutta italia possono pubblicare i
desideri espressi dai loro ospiti e
chiunque può scegliere uno di questi
desideri e realizzarlo l'anno scorso
centocinquanta cose semplici magari che
appartengono a un momento felice della
storia di questa persona quindi magari
semplicemente un libro un paio di
zoccoli di legno o un profumo quel
particolare profumo ma anche un'uscita
con gli amici per prendere un aperitivo
o per tornare a vedere la chiesetta del
proprio matrimonio per andare dal
parrucchiere per sentirsi ancora belli
quindi cose semplici ma non banali
se vivi in casa di riposo gli anziani
come vedete nella foto hanno potuto fare
cose ancora che credevano di non poter
fare più cose nelle quali loro
riconoscono la propria identità il
proprio sapere e nel nell'essere in
quella situazione sono esattamente dove
vorrebbero essere questa è iris 87 anni
il suo desiderio era di tornare a fare
un giro in moto sul lungolago e allora
affidato questo desiderio alla rete e
intanto ha preparato la sua giacca di
pelle roberto poco più che trentenne ha
subito detto che doveva essere lui a
realizzare questo sogno
e quando si è presentato nel salone
della casa di riposo con la sua yamaha
fa tutti hanno visto la gioia sul volto
di questa donna giulia ha 80 anni dopo
essere stata insegnante per 40 anni nel
liceo della sua città aveva un unico
desiderio tornare in aula in cattedra
per un'ultima lezione maria
che ha frequentato lo stesso liceo ha
organizzato per lei questa mattinata
speciale giulia ha parlato per quasi due
ore della virtù dell'accoglienza nella
società greca e romana e in aula non
volava una mosca è scappata anche
qualche lacrima quando ha citato la fuga
da di enea con il padre sulle
spalle e il suo figliolo per mano
antonio 95 anni voleva tornare su una
nave militare e ha espresso questo
desiderio sapendo che non è che si può
avere tutto
e invece la marina militare di brindisi
gli ha permesso di tornare di visitare
la nave san giusto e l'ha accolto con un
gruppo di militari che hanno confidato
ad antonio un po delle loro malinconie e
lui molto commosso ha raccontato cose
che non aveva mai detto
giampietro 86 anni aveva avuto uno ha
detto un'unica passione nella sua vita
sciare ma in carrozzina non lo può più
fare elisabetta e stefania hanno
organizzato per lui una trasferta in
montagna e nella sua tuta rossa l'hanno
visto prendere la funivia e scendere
dalle piste innevate con la faccia piena
di sorrisi e di lacrime
i nipoti quelli che sono andati a
conoscere questi anziani sono rimasti
totalmente attratti da queste persone
una di loro dice quando ho conosciuto
quella signora bisbetica non ho potuto
più fare a meno di tornare da lei e
quando non posso andare il sabato le
telefono perché lei è la vecchia che
sarò io ruvida diretta non fa niente per
piacere a nessuno
ed è proprio per quello che aveva
piaciuta da subito i nipoti di babbo
natale sono quelle persone che si sono
messe in movimento per andare a cercare
il regalo perfetto per uno sconosciuto e
si son detti il regalo fatto me stesso
perché quando ho visto quegli occhi
pieni di luce così felici mi sono detto
sono io la causa di tutta quella
felicità
vi racconto di ivana che ci ha scritto
questo sarà il primo natale per me senza
la mia adorata nonna rosa su facebook ho
visto la foto di una signora che aveva
ricevuto per natale un profumo il
profumo che io regalavo a lei ogni anno
e allora con questa emozione nel cuore
mi son detta io voglio fare un regalo a
un'altra signora e scegliendo tra i
regali sul sito ha trovato il desiderio
di maria giacinta che vive a milano ma
che è originaria della sua stessa zona
di foggia e che aveva chiesto di poter
assaporare un piatto di orecchiette
fumanti e ivan ha detto non solo gliele
spedirò io gliele voglio proprio portare
anche se devo prendere l'aereo per la
prima volta perché andando da lei sarà
come a tornare dalla mia nonna poterle
dare un bacio e il suo regalo di natale
anche gli operatori hanno detto il
regalo fatto a me stesso perché ho
ritrovato il valore il senso del mio
lavoro e tutte le persone che hanno
speso 5 minuti per dare un'occhiata alle
foto alle storie di questi anziani si
son detti mi sono donato un momento di
tenerezza
ho ritrovato il senso del natale io oggi
vorrei convincervi che dedicare un
momento alla gioia di un anziano per
natale è un gesto d'amore verso se
stessi io vi vorrei dire che l'incontro
con l'anziano è un dono
il tempo trascorso insieme è un dono la
relazione che si crea è un dono infilate
le lenti dei volontari
guardate con questi occhi i vostri
vecchi
sfogliate le pagine di questi libri e
ascoltateli ma come piace a voi essere
ascoltati perché possano sentire che
sono esattamente dove vorrebbero essere
perché quel dove è accanto a voi ed è
dove si sta bene
[Applauso]